Ryan why did you want to use the form of
a whodunit to tell your story well I I
grew up really guys for being being here
by the way Rebecca thanks for doing this
and yeah you guys whatever but yeah
three days of proof I grew up reading
Agatha Christie I love whodunits and
also I just have a memory as a kid of
going to see the ones with Peter Ustinov
as Poirot
so death on the Nile evil Under the Sun
and they were big all-star cast I
remember guys seen them with my whole
family I'm feeling like there's no this
is the most fun you can possibly have in
a movie or these type of movies and
wanting to do that but also I mean you
know the whodunit kind of it would very
often we see it today it's done as a
period piece and the idea of doing it in
America in 2019 and not just doing
Colonel Mustard with the cell phone but
really plugging into America in 2019
that seemed like that could be really
interesting
Daniel was your character written as
southern and what was your approach I
mean I obviously tone in your voice I'm
sorting something yes how did you how
did you find your southern accent and
your sort of southern soul I guess I it
was in the script
I mean Rhondda written something that
was damn near perfect as far as I was
concerned and it kind of arrived and I
read it very quickly and said yes very
loudly and let's do this and we shot the
script and yes it was it was a I think I
said southern accent but then but then
we work together and we narrow we ended
up being a Mississippi accent because
it's be based it on Shelby Foote and
Shelby Foote yeah I mean I had I had
Tennessee Williams there but Tennessee
Williams flamboyance and I wanted we
wanted to be sonorous and pleasing to
the ear basically so yeah yeah it was
there I just I just sucked it up and
spat it out basically ROM movies of this
of this scale are kind of increasingly
rare I mean there's giant movies and
little movies that get theatrical
releases or they go to streamers but a
movie like this
getting a kind of traditional theatrical
release is unfortunately not that common
was it a challenge to put it together
and from a producing sense I have to say
not really we put them the whole movie
together really quickly Ryan wrote the
script started writing the script in
January last year and we wrapped like
Christmas so and really run delivered
the script that he felt comfortable by
end of August beginning of September a
week later we get Danielle and six weeks
later we were shooting but we you know
it's John removi with Ryan writing and
directing and all-star cast like this
done at a reasonable price we we felt
very comfortable Jamie I gather you guys
shot this in a house in Massachusetts
where you spent some time a little bit
about the house and V and what you all
did there when you were before you
started shooting
it is a real house it is in
Massachusetts and we shot thanks good
night folks you know the house is a
character in the movie what I love is
that it has it starts out in now I'm not
gonna spoil anything it starts out as
this sort of ancestral home it carries
all the tropes of ancestral homes it's
the the you know passed on cookie that
we all want a piece of and I love the
fact that it was just what was it a drug
deal or he just Bobby in the 80s tax
rebate or something I just I'd I sort of
love that idea of it the house is
gorgeous
the secret although again we're not
spoiling anything is that the library
where the interrogations take place was
actually a separate house somebody
talked about that house it was that
house with the concrete it was built by
suffragettes who had a fear of fires so
it's made out of concrete which made it
quite was welcoming house it had the
two-story library which is what
obviously Ryan wanted for that sequence
so but the main house is is really it's
an extraordinary place and
we were very lucky to shoot there the
people that owned it have become friends
and it was fun I assume your production
designer did some things oh my goodness
that's not they don't live among the
wall of knives yeah they would want us
to know they are not insane people their
house doesn't usually by David crank
who's our production designer who has is
a genius he's collaborated with Jack
Fiske on the Paul Thomas Anderson's
movie in Terrence Malick's movies he and
our center curator David Schlessinger
David the Schlessinger is the one who
really scoured Massachusetts and beyond
to find all the amazing stuff inside
that house and dressed it and it's
amazing I gave them the the reference of
the 1970s version of sleuth one of my
favorite films and told them to go to
town and God they did they filled it up
Don was it fun to play a kept man yeah
I'm wondering when does it start
no Richard is kind of the pure
personification of the of the family but
he's out front about the fact that he
does nothing
he does it well yeah I'm kind of kind of
half boos they're really well-dressed
yeah well thank you honey
and III kind of figured him you know
I've known some characters like this and
I in my life that kind of walk around
with kind of a you know a little boozy
buzz on on all day all day buzz and you
know and going to the Country Club and
trying to figure out ways to fill this
day it was fabulous
and if you're going to be a trophy
husband well I will say I think Jenny
Egan needs to be given a lot of the
costume designer so besides the set
decoration the production design the
costume design was also extraordinary
and she really helps the actors become
those people you know the production
design informs it but
really lets us inhabit it and she was
amazing I loved working with her
Ryan kind of underpinning the plotting
there's a lot of sharp kind of timely
critiques sort of social ideas people
are talking about immigration they're
talking about the sort of delusional
about their own class and how they got
where they were what informed these
ideas how did you decide how to use them
and put them in the movie yeah I mean
then you know that all kind of came from
just saying well if we're gonna kind of
you know again plug this into 2018 let's
really do it let's not let's not be
subtle let's just say all this stuff and
in a way that hopefully is entertaining
and you can you can go and have kind of
a cathartic laugh about but the movie
obviously also has a perspective on all
of it so yeah and I mean you know that
Agatha Christie was never a political
writer per se she was never an
incredibly socially conscious writer but
one thing she always did was she was
always engaging with her time she was
engaging with contemporary British
society especially through her
characters and very often through her
through her female characters she was
dealing with kind of like gender roles
in British society a lot and very
conscious of that stuff so the idea of
again using this kind of thing we often
think of as this gilded antiquated form
to you know to put a lot of this stuff
on the table in the way that still is in
the context of a big popular
entertainment you can take your family
to that same opponent I think it's
important to remember it was it's not
told from a liberal bent it's there's
plenty of red meat and blue me to throw
at each other across the table and what
I love is at the center of the movie is
truth which is love which is honored to
Armus who is a super star on the rise
she is extraordinary in the movie but I
love that in the center of this
political fight this familiar fight this
familial fight this this you know
disparity of wealth and privilege and
all the rest of it that at the center of
the whole thing is the only person who
truly loved him he
the only person who truly just loved him
and didn't need anything from him except
the relationship and she's the one with
the loss from that relationship and I
just think to Center that in a movie
that is as amusing and perfect as this I
think is really very much a great
testament to Ryan and the piece and and
the whole thing well I thank you that's
all the time that we have it was a
pleasure talking Rebecca thank you
everyone